well reports of anti-social behavior in
recent years have thankfully been
declining but we do take it very
seriously because we think that the
public are entitled to feel safe in
their own communities to be able to walk
down their Road or visit the local High
Street go to the local park without
feeling any sense of fear intimidation
or Menace and that's why we take
antisocial Behavior as seriously as
higher harm forms of crime that's why
the prime minister is going to be
launching an antisocial Behavior action
plan in just a few hours time which
includes uh hotspot policing that we're
funding to where police and Council
officers can surge into areas where
there are high levels of ASB to prevent
it and to deal with the consequences
where they find it we're funding the use
of sort of instant restorative justice
out of court disposals where people who
commit on social behavior will have to
do community payback uh very very
quickly so if they've been spraying
graffiti then get it cleaned up really
quickly we're also proposing to ban
nitrous oxide unless of course people
are using it for legitimate commercial
purposes because we think that is partly
fueling anti-social behaviors being
consumed on a very widespread basis so
we take this very seriously we think the
public take it seriously and that's why
we're announcing this plan today you've
been empowered 13 years what's taking
you so long well as I say antisocial
Behavior reports about social behavior
have been falling in recent years which
is very welcome overall crime actually
since um 2010 has dropped by 48
according to the crime survey which is
also very welcome
um but we're not complacent and we'd
like to do a lot more uh hence the extra
police officers that are being recruited
by the end of this month just a few days
time we're on track to have more police
officers than we've ever had at any time
in this country's history it's also why
we're launching initiatives how many are
we going to have sorry how many police
officers will we have well we're on
track to get up to about 149
000 the previous Peak which was in 2010
was 145 000 but we don't know the exact
figures but we're sort of on track to
deliver that okay we'll know for sure by
the end of April isn't the fact that you
got rid of 21
000 police officers previously partly
um
means that we've seen anti-social
Behavior rise on the streets well I say
reports of antisocial Behavior have been
going down when George was born and
David Cameron had to make those savings
sort of in the Years immediately after
2010 it was let's remind ourselves
because the previous labor government
left the country bankrupt so George
Osborne and David Cameron had to make
difficult choices
but now but now the uh you know the
economy has been doing uh better over
the last few years we've been able to
invest in these extra offices and we're
going to actually have more police
officers as I said uh by the end of this
month we're on track to have more
officers than we have ever had at any
time before any country's history but
it's never a good idea to cut police is
it
well as I say they were very difficult
economic circumstances the last Labor
government uh bankrupt the country their
then Chief secretary left a note saying
there's no money left so unfortunately
David Cameron and George Osborne
essentially had no choice but to do that
to make the books balance we've now
prioritized uh delivering record numbers
which is I think a really welcome uh
welcome step it will help with
antisocial behavior that we're talking
about today it will of course also help
with combating more serious crime as
well okay let me put this to you if I
made vast majority of our police are
amazing and you know thank goodness that
we have the police service that we do
here in the United Kingdom but there are
a few bad apples that we heard about
last week however today the children's
commissioner has reported on uh black
children being disproportionately
affected by stop and search and also we
were hearing about child Q who was strip
search while she was having her period I
mean what do we do about that yeah well
I'm deeply concerned about that I'm
going to study racial d'souza's report
very carefully There are rules in place
the pace codes governing the way strip
and search should be done and it looks
like Rachel has the children's Committee
of Rachel de Souza has uncovered uh
evidence that those codes are not always
being complied with that is of great
concern to me so I will be looking into
that and discussing that with policing
in terms of how the numbers it's worth
keeping in mind that the on average
there are about two of these strip
searches a day so we're not talking
about huge numbers but we do but we of
course that's right but we do need to
make sure they're being done according
uh to the rules there is also a
safeguarding element because quite often
young people are being exploited by drug
dealers who are essentially coercing
them into concealing drugs in Intimate
body cavities so it is important to
identify that and find that where it's
happening so those young people can be
safeguarded but it's got to be done in
the right way and if the rules and the
codes are not being properly complied
with that is of course a real concern
let's rush through two or three of those
subjects if we may the migration Bill 60
Rebels trying to force a tougher path
um than the one that we're already
seeing from the Home Secretary your
thoughts on that well I think this bill
is very important I mean the public
expect these small boats to be stopped
the Prime Minister one of the prime
minister's five priorities is to stop
the boats and this bill is designed to
deliver that I don't think anyone could
doubt the prime minister's commitment or
the home secretary's commitment uh I
think she as I understand it she is
discussing these various amendments with
members of parliament I'm sure she's you
know in listening mode as always
um but this bill is a well-designed
well-constructed bill designed to stop
the boats which the public I think
expect the government to do they're
obviously listening um to the Home
Secretary we're just hearing actually
from our sources that they are dropping
uh that that Amendment or attempted
Amendment to the migration Bill those 60
Rebels so there we go just uh as we're
chatting to you breaking news I think we
call it in the in the trade
um talk to me about the SMP leadership
your colleague Michael go struggled to
find think of anything that Nicholas
sturgeon had done well during her time
in office can you think of something
well I think looking forward rather than
backwards the UK government the
Westminster government will work
constructively with like with I know
with uh with whoever does that mean you
can't think of anything either well I
mean look I think the the new Scottish
government or the new Scottish first
Minister
um need to concentrate on working on the
real day-to-day problems that Scotland
uh faces in common with other places I
mean Scotland has issues with its NHS
with its Education Service it's got
record levels of drug deaths and I think
the new first Minister should
concentrate on fixing those issues
working constructively with the UK
government we're ready to work
constructively with the new first
Minister but our viewers they should
concentrate on on those fundamental
issues and not continue to agitate to
break up the country and has that given
you time to think of something that you
think that she's done well I mean to be
fair to Nicholas sturgeon she is a
phenomenal political communicator and
you know she has managed to
um you know win Landslide elections
despite uh having a pretty bad track
record of delivery so let's give a full
marks for political communication okay
what about quasi-coating and Matt
Hancock gray and Brady they look like
complete plonkers well it was a pretty
idifying spectacle that is certainly
true
um I think it's very important that we
have transparency over these things so
had they had that thing we saw been been
real then any agreement they would have
entered into would have been completely
disclosed to the public which is really
important
um Parliament I think has also recently
strengthened the ban on paid lobbying uh
this is where you know would you have
fallen for that though well I hope not I
mean ultimately I hope not I mean it was
pretty it was pretty um pretty
unedifying as I say yeah but
they would have they 'd be breaking it
the rules though did they
as far as I can tell uh no they didn't
but had they gone ahead with the
proposed Arrangement they would have all
have been completely transparently
um disclosed so so journalists like you
and others would have would have seen
what was um what was going on and of
course there are MPS who do
um work that is quite important so
people like Maria Caufield one of my
colleagues does work as a nurse in
addition to her job as a minister other
people do work on their family farms so
there's there are things people do which
are completely sort of reasonable
um but yeah what we saw on our TV
screens uh in the last few days was not
an edifying spectacle no it's not
Hancock worth ten thousand pounds a day
do you think well I wouldn't pay ten
thousand pounds
it's good to see you as always thanks so
much you do thank you